There was an interesting exchange on CNN during
an interview with Donald Trump's economic
adviser, Larry Kudlow, and Kudlow didn't necessarily
seem drunk this time, although he did have
some interesting hiccups during the interview
and some some kind of strange slurring.
But he he wasn't making sense, regardless
of whether he had been drinking, I think is
the point I'm trying to make.
And Larry Kudlow tried telling CNN anchor
Jake Tapper that the United States is dealing
with Corona virus in a safe way and that the
Trump administration has figured out how to
do it.
Now, fact check before we watch the video.
As of right now, the United States is the
major country with the eighth most cases per
capita in the world.
And the ace eighth most deaths per capita
in the world.
Now, when I say major country, there are tiny
territories like San Marino, for example,
which have worse numbers on a per capita basis
than the U.S.
It only moves the U.S. up two spots.
So, so, so, so it's not a big change in either
case.
But Trump and people around him, despite these
horrible numbers, continue to insist, partially
out of desperation, partially out of dishonesty,
that the United States is just doing great
on the virus.
And Larry Kudlow tried saying it to Jake Tapper
and Jake Tapper just laughed and Larry Kudlow
face.
And it's compelling to watch.
Let's take a look.
And Kudlow, you will hear shifting directly
from singing the praises of the economy into
singing Trump's praises on Corona virus.
And Jake Tapper just can't take it.
My point is this.
We are in a strong rebound.
Lower taxes and lower regulations going way
back are still in place and businesses are
re opening.
We are learning to deal with the virus in
a targeted, safe, preventive way.
So it's not dependent.
All I'm saying is a little some targeted assistance
would go a long way.
We're not we're not learning to live with
the virus, Larry, that we just had four days
in a row of more than 50000 infections.
The death rate is the highest in the world.
But let let's focus on the economic aspect,
cause that's your area of expertize.
I guess one I just want to say.
Yeah.
Just check one, two.
Check one.
Just one second.
I want to clarify.
Living with a virus.
Look, 5000 experts just signed a petition
led by people from Harvard, Stanford, Oxford
University.
These are scientists.
These are doctors.
These are health care workers who say we can
deal with this virus going on while we're
getting new therapies.
We're getting new vaccines are coming around.
It's not just living with the virus.
As long as we protect them vulnerable, as
long as we preserve the key guidelines.
Yes, we can get through this.
We are not going to shut down the whole economy.
Nobody.
There is no reason for that.
We will take care of the vulnerable.
That's the key point.
Well, there's so much that you just said.
But again, I had you on to talk about the
economy.
Not not not health care matters in terms of
well-being by the key guidelines.
I mean, you might want to tell the guy in
the building behind you, but that's a separate
issue.
So Jake's mistake there is he referred to
the building behind Kudlow as if Kudlow is
at the White House and it's set on screen.
Kudlow is actually at his country estate in
Connecticut for the interview.
Not at the White House.
But Jake Tapper is right to laugh.
Record number of cases for the last two months.
Once again, four days ago, over the weekend.
And if we want to look not just that one day,
but at the seven day moving average, the average
cases have been increasing since September
13th.
So we are now a full month into another spike.
And remember, when you look at this graph,
you see we had that first spike into mid-April
and then we got back down to about 20000 cases
a day.
And for some reason, at 20000 cases a day,
everything opened up.
And then we spiked to 75000 cases a day in
mid-July.
You can see it on the graph.
Now, we've had more openings since dipping
to 35000 cases a day and we're back up to
50 cases a day.
So, unfortunately, there are people who saw
getting down to 35000 cases a day as a victory.
It's not a victory.
And if this trend continues, the next peak
could be 100000 cases a day.
And if that's the case, it is going to be
a very, very dark winter, both the literally
as the clocks get ready to change.
And it is going to be this sunset will be
very early in the Northeast and metaphorically,
it will be a very dark winter.
As Dr. Foushee said, we need to get down to
an average of 10000 cases a day to even remotely
being able to say we are controlling the virus.
And even 10000 cases a day is a lot.
The last time I think about this number, the
last time we had only 10000 cases per day
was last March.
Since then, every day there are at least 10000
cases, some days as many as 75000 cases.
Now, as far as Larry Kudlow is concerned,
Kudlow said back in February that the Trump.
Station had contained the virus, February
means laughable and as a reminder, the official
corona virus death toll is likely way too
low in the United States.
This is something we talked about maybe two
months ago, and I think it's worth revisiting.
Officially, two hundred and 21000, 222 have
died from Corona virus.
That's a massive, stunning, tragic number.
And it didn't have to be that way.
But that's the official number.
Mortality in the United States was more than
280000 deaths higher than during the first
eight months of 2020.
Then sorry.
During the first eight months of 2020, mortality
was more than 280000 deaths higher than during
any previous thought period of the first eight
months of the year.
Going back five years.
So, again, it looks like the official death
toll of 221 is well below the real corona
virus death toll.
And you also have to remember, because of
the virus, fewer people are traveling, fewer
people are walking around, driving around.
You probably have to subtract out some deaths
from some other causes because there are people
just sitting at home reducing the number of
deaths from other causes this year.
But Kudlow and others and Trump himself continue
to insist.
We've won.
We're winning.
We're the best.
That's over.
I don't know that anybody believes it at this
point.
I think even when they interview Trump at
rallies and they say we've won.
I don't even know that they believe it, to
be totally honest with you